so we'll really explore the role
microbes play in human wellbeing health
and disease and we have really worked
hard at designing this program to be
available fully online and to be
rewarding to students and all the way to
experienced researchers that can utilize
the types of data and the analysis
methods to get biological insight out of
this high quality high-throughput data
we plan to cover two major topics in
metagenomics one of them is the analysis
of 16s and 18s ribosomal RNA that can
allow us to study the hyper variable
regions and understand composition of
the microbial community when we talked
about 16s RNA but also will talk about
other types of microbial genomes and
we'll talk about genomics in the context
of an understanding how these different
strains of viruses and bacteria interact
with environmental challenges and
develop and how can we study that using
genomic data so we are starting today
with an overview of the program so what
we really want to talk about are two
things we want to talk about
expectations what might you expect from
participating in this program and talk
little bit more about the schedule and
deadlines and important dates of this
program so what we will do is we will
meet online just like today to cover a
variety of topics and typically we will
go from more theoretical topics to then
more and more practical where we will
learn how to analyze data and we will
have a chance to review specific data
sets these data sets are all going to be
from the public domain so everybody will
be able to read the publication about
how the data was generated understand
why the data was generated analyze the
data and then compare the results to
what the authors of the publication
showed in their method section so really
the program is going to cover a variety
of theoretical background information
with some practical skills practical
ways to analyze data and then also
conceptually how to think about
different types of projects that are
possible with this kind of data so we
will talk about like I mentioned before
online sessions practical and they are
going to be supplemented by online
materials that you will have access to
on our educational platform or portal
where you can find a variety of
different projects and a variety of
different online lessons and really
learn on your own schedule now some of
the topics that we will go through
include understanding the microbiome how
microbial communities live and function
together and how they affect agriculture
organ function and health so we'll talk
about the microbial community and how it
functions we'll talk about sequencing
including 16s and 18s ribosomal RNA
sequencing but also genomic sequencing
next-generation sequencing in general
and how the development of these methods
are really allowing us to understand
better the microbe
communities and what is this
understanding actually produced how can
we apply this understanding of the way
the microbes live and work together
between themselves and with the host how
can we apply and use that information
then we'll talk about several ways to
analyze metagenomic data so there are
two main aspects of analysis of
metagenomic data where we will talk
about the challenge of accurate assembly
of a meta-genome a genome of a specific
for example variation a species for
example as you know in viruses there's
this concept of quasi species really a
diverse population of the same species
but that has a lot of variants and so
therefore they are not represented by
single genomes like we typically think
of human as the human genome well if you
talk about Ebola or you talk about flu
you're really talking about a community
of genomes and we can still study this
community of genomes by looking at the
variation at the genomic level
understanding that there's a
representative of a population that we
are looking at and we will talk about
the non genome based metagenomics so
really metagenomics as analysis of the
microbial community based on their
variability so we'll look at genome
composition in a sample understanding
that this is a sample coming from a
whole variety of species that work and
live together and function together and
so we are looking at their function as
in entity as a microbiome and so will
then understand the microbiome and how
it really functions and how we can study
variation in composition as well as
variation at the genomic level to
understand infectiousness or different
phenotypes related to infectious
diseases we'll talk about phenotypes
that are related to for example
how much fruit a certain plant produces
based on rice of bacteria how infectious
and how fast the disease spreads based
on genomic understanding of the genome
variation as well as how can we link the
composition of the microbiome for
example with a stress response or some
kind of a well-being or a healthy versus
sick condition as well as how do we
understand resistance to different drugs
including resistance to antibiotics so
those are some of the topics that we
will cover and for each one of these
topics we will provide you with an
example a data set that could be studied
in the context of that topic so for
example we will have several projects
each project is taken from a publication
so we'll have access to the protocol of
how they generated the data how they
sequence the data how they analyze the
data what are the conclusions from that
analysis and we can repeat the same
steps to really understand what we can
learn and how can leverage that example
to think of similar types of studies one
big aspect of metagenomics and the
popularity of metagenomics is the
emergence of 16s metagenomic sequencing
so amplified 16s ribosomal RNA
sequencing has really reduced
significantly the cost of sequencing and
therefore study of a microbiome so in
November in November we will start by
talking about the aspects of sequencing
how does this sequencing really work so
we will talk about how this could be a
very low or moderately costly study it
really focuses on a 1,500 base region
that could be extracted and then
amplified to the sequence either the
full typically the full sequence
across the whole sample and you can
therefore study this hyper variable
region that can provide species specific
signature that are very useful for
bacterial identification so those are
some of the methods of sequencing where
you can look at amplicon of just
specific regions of 16s ribosomal RNA
you can study the whole length of 16s
ribosomal RNA or you can also even do
the full genomic kind of a standard
sequencing without amplifying anything
and we'll look at different examples of
how these different types of sequencing
methods can be used in the context of
these studies when it comes to
sequencing the hyper variable region
we're really talking about a portion of
the ribosome so we're talking about the
RNA that encodes the bottom part of the
ribosome when it sits on the RNA and we
will look at how these different regions
so you can see those regions over here
on this side this is for e.coli
you can look how these regions could be
used to very specifically understand the
composition of the microbiome they are
highly conserved within the species and
therefore and they're pretty short and
so therefore you can sequence a lot of
them so you can have good coverage and
at the same time they are very fairly
well annotated so instead of trying to
assemble whole genomes of different
representatives of species within your
sample you're able to just use a
database and then learn about the
composition and the different
proportions of species phyla and family
within your sample
so that's when we will talk about the
microbe the microbiome as a functional
bacterial community so really the
microbiome is a composition of fungi
bacteria and viruses it's essentially
all the microorganisms in a single
sample that it has stable condition
within a specific environment so this
could be an ecological sample so sample
from water it or dirt
it could be a sample from the gut for
example or it could be a fecal sample so
we we think of the microbiome as a
functional community it has a specific
set of functions and it is really
defined by the microbiome stable
condition and so we will also look at
how the stable condition can change as a
result of different environmental
factors for example we can think of the
food the intake of nutrients the food
processing of that food inside the human
gut as being a process that is fairly
stable and it could be disrupted by the
change in diet so one of the projects
that we will look at is actually how
does the changing of diet even when it
is not long term exposure or to really
change the physiology of the host but a
short term a kind of transplantation of
a microbiome can change behavior and so
this is a very interesting area that
really points to the functional aspect
of the microbiome the microbiome can
really in the guy at the microbiome in
the gut can affect the way that we
function we think we interact and that's
a fairly new area that is being studied
now in terms of the microbiome now the
microbiome actually has these stable
communities in a variety areas around
our body and we can study the
as these stable communities so skin
microbiome vaginal microbiome gut
microbiome different types of micro
biomes and so now you can think of those
as ways to study how different processes
occur that are very critical to human
health right we talk about for example
skin diseases and we talk about the oral
microbiome and aspects of oral cancers
or dentistry and things like that we can
talk about the gut microbiome and how it
relates to intake of food ability to
process specific types of food and of
course how that affects our response to
different treatments because of course a
lot of the treatments come through the
gut so we take pills and then through
the stomach that get into the
bloodstream right so a lot of that has
to do with that functional microbial
community so we can use a database that
essentially tells us how taxonomic
classification of these different
microorganisms can essentially work
together you can see here composition of
different types of bacteria how the
composition could be studied to
understand the health and the processes
the functionality of these so to say
organs the microbiomes
associated with different parts of the
body and so we will look at different
examples that will help us understand
how this actually works now there are
some challenges associated with analysis
of such data a lot of these challenges
are related to the understanding of how
sequencing actually works and so
sequencing when we sequence these hyper
variable regions we will have a
challenge of aligning the short reads
and then making sure that so typically
this is paired and reads so we have more
reliability of
the sequence itself but nevertheless
there are a number of methods that have
been designed to address some of these
challenges how to identify properly
reads that were aligned correctly how to
identify the hypervariable regions
correctly how to map them to the
database which database to use how do we
create these organizational taxonomic
units or ODU's and how do we really then
use the composition based on these ot
use using clustering techniques etc so
those are challenges related to the 16s
ribosomal RNA but also we'll talk about
other challenges if you take a sample
and your sequence total RNA what are
some of the challenges there with
assembly with k-mers so really assembly
of genome entities that are not
necessarily mentioned in databases so
we'll talk about some of those
challenges as well and it's going to be
very important for us to really
understand again the theoretical aspects
of what these challenges are but then
also to look at practical examples how
do we use in a practical sense this or
another type of data and how do we go
from sequencing the data mapping the
data on some database or on a collection
of genomes and then actually getting
some biologically meaningful information
that is significant enough for us to say
something about something like the
health of the gut or some of these other
examples that we talked about so as I
said there is a variety of different
databases that are available to do so so
we have different databases like
Greenjeans
Silva NCBI NCBI of course hosts a lot of
data that has been submitted on a
variety of different genomes but just
taking all of the genomes and mapping
everything that we have in our reads on
those genomes you know there's going to
be a lot of overlap so the data is going
to be noise so some of these they
were actually more curated and validated
biologically to help us reduce the
amount of noise that we have in our data
and we'll look at some of those examples
where we will compare the different
databases and really try to run our
analysis so that we understand in which
case which database which reference
database is going to be more useful so
we'll have a whole session dedicated to
kind of a review of some of these
databases and we will particularly look
at how to compare the results
so Silva for example is a comprehensive
online resource for quality checked and
aligned ribosomal RNA sequence data
which is important because it really
validates a lot of these so biologically
actually uses the sequences that are in
the database sequencing can actually be
more confusing because of chimeras and
because of different wrong assembly of
organizational taxonomic units now on
the other hand we will also look at
examples of specific projects developed
by NCBI and FDA and other regulatory
agencies that actually are more focused
on detection presence or absence of
specific species that are had that have
been understood as being harmful to a
specific process so an important aspect
of that is really taking and looking at
the database design from the standpoint
of how it is going to be used so we'll
take a look at some of those examples
now way to apply practically from this
type of understanding this type of
knowledge about how the sequencing works
and the types of data that you can
generate is to actually try and run a
pipeline so the data to is a good
example of a pipeline that is
specifically designed to address a lot
of the challenges that we talked about
up until now related to 16s right
so Moe amplicon sequencing so we'll take
a look at that pipeline and we will
apply it to a number of different
projects to understand how it addresses
some of these challenges that we
discussed and I want to mention how the
program is built around like I mentioned
theoretical concepts project examples
and some practical tools now a lot of
times you will find that courses require
all kinds of installation of software
and really a variety of different
packages and that's where a lot of
programs fail like this so we would we
would like to believe that our program
has addressed that challenge very
efficient efficiently by putting all of
the packages that are required behind a
visual interface that is easy to use now
this is a functional usable interface
that you can apply to exemplar projects
that we will go through you can apply to
public domain projects that you will
source from places like NCBI and you can
also use it for your own data it's a
fully developed research platform so I
want to talk a little bit about that
platform so that we can understand how
it works
so the program itself is going to
consist of online sessions like this one
it will also give you access to online
materials that mohit pasted links in the
chat to some of the courses that we have
online for your independent learning and
then another aspect will be actually
going through datasets and using those
datasets in the context of analysis so I
just wanted to make sure that it's
fairly straightforward for all of you to
see how this works so let's take a look
at this platform really quickly in the
context of
metagenomic analysis so you can see that
the server t - bio info platform is
available for anyone you can actually
request access for research use or for
educational use just by filling out this
form right here but you can also learn
about in the context of this program
about a different several different
areas on the platform are going to be
related so for example here you can see
the amplicon 16s and 18s ribosomal RNA
and we'll take a look now at just one of
the examples here you see the full
sequence assembly of total RNA and use
of that data by mapping it on a variety
of different genomes and you also have a
number of sections here related to
biology so we will actually cover
several of these sections in the program
and we will help you also find the
packages that you might need if you
would like to set up your own pipeline
design your own pipeline or run this
pipeline on your own server we will also
help you identify packages in our and
design the pipeline to work on urine if
you're interested but in the context of
this program we'll primarily rely on
this platform to understand how to
process the data so let's just take a
look really quickly at a demo now anyone
can request a demo for free and you can
look at how this works really to
understand the concept behind the logic
of this pipeline so if we click on start
here we can read a little bit about what
we've been talking about and here you
can see what the amplicon sequencing of
16s hyper variable region and you can
understand a little bit about these
conserved regions and really the types
of pipelines are really designed to
address some of the typical challenges
with this data so once we
click on okay we can start the data to
pipeline so the data to pipeline starts
with filtering so you really have to
reduce the number of reads to reduce the
noise and you can read here in each one
of the pop-up so you can actually read a
fairly detailed description of what the
pipeline does with explanations for
example this is an explanation of read
quality where certain reads are high
quality and they're kept some readings
are low quality and they are not kept
and then you can see also the output of
this step would be kind of an assessment
of general properties of reads for this
kind of filtering and you can also see a
full description and a detailed tutorial
on how to implement so for example if we
go here you can see how to install this
package yourself and this is something
that is based on a number of packages in
our so anyone can actually install this
pipeline but let's click on OK and now
we will look at several other steps that
help us prepare the organizational
taxonomic units ot use so now we will go
through consensus of Oh to use and
really data to pipeline was designed to
improve quality of 16s metagenomic
sequencing so you can see for example
the core data to method correct
substitution and indel errors but
chimeras remain fortunately the accuracy
of the sequence variants after denoising
makes identifying chimeras simpler and
so really it is all about having high
quality data and then once we have high
quality input data we can accurately map
that data to a reference database so
here you can see that this was done by
mapping the data on the Silva database
and you can see that really what the
silver database contains are just
sequences of these hyper variable
regions for a variety
of different species click on ok now we
need to construct the phylogenetic tree
so Philo seek is an hour package that
allows us to construct this tree and
what we will see are the actual
relationships between the abundance and
the type of level of organizational
taxonomic units that we have chosen
species phylum family and then we can
also think of a comparison between our
samples for example we can think of the
composition inside a sample which is
called alpha diversity or the comparison
of two samples or two groups of samples
that could be called beta diversity so
what would be the output the output of
such a pipeline really will produce a
table of abundance where we will see Oh
to use these organizational taxonomic
units across our samples we will be able
to identify what those Oh to use
represent in the organizational
taxonomic units and then we will also
have the ability to see composition
study the composition of the microbiome
so now we can click on OK and here we
have some outputs and those are the
outputs that we will be studied so now
the question is what is the data what
are these samples how do we interpret
what we have been studying in the
context of the project so that is a
little bit about the practical use of
the platform again the platform itself
is really comprehensive and allows us to
process these types of specific datasets
that we looked at here it also provides
access to some machine learning and data
mining tools has some very useful
utilities for annotation and
visualization of data and also has a lot
of different types of data that you can
work with so really the platform is
designed for multi-omics data and if you
think of the microbiome or if you think
about any microbial data
we typically think of that microbial
data in correlation with some other type
of data and one way to study this is
really the host microbiome interaction
how does the change in composition of
the microbiome affect the response from
the host for example the immune response
from the host or the response in terms
of for example response to treatment
right development of resistance how does
it affect the population scale when we
look at for example spread of an
infectious disease in a geographic
endemic how do we look at that region
how do we look at speed of progression
of that disease how do we look at
response from different types of
populations etc so really it's all about
the relationship between the host and
the agent so going back to our overview
here as we looked at we will study the
data to pipeline and really understand
what this data to pipeline does how do
we merge it with other packages that are
going to be useful for visualization
downstream analysis validation how do we
incorporate the t bio platform provided
interface with other types of tools in
our in Excel in other environments where
we can really analyze the data further
to get granularity from our data to be
able to interpret the meaning of that
biologically so in the sense of
understanding what this ribosomal RNA
data can give us we really can look at
several different examples understand
the outputs understand the relationship
between the hyper variable regions and
this type of study that looks at
composition or alpha and beta diversity
so then after we've kind of gone through
the basics right we talked about
different types of microbial communities
we talked about different types of
organisms viruses
bacteria fungi and then we talked about
how we can study different types of
sequencing techniques that allow us to
study different aspects of these
microbial populations we will start
thinking about projects and so what
we've done is we've prepared a number of
exemplar projects the American gut
microbiome project called just simply
the American gut is a good example this
is a citizen science project that was
designed to collect samples from
participants like you and I we can
actually all do it at the cost of 99
dollars any one of us can participate
and contribute our samples to this
project really what they did is they
studied the microbe microbiomes from
people from all over the US and I think
now they've expanded to other countries
as well we can have out looking at the
type of data that we have available and
how it can help explain some of these
self-reported self-reported phenotypes
we also will look at several other
examples that we've prepared as fully
digested projects for specifically this
program so we'll look at gut brain axis
again the relationship about between
microbial composition and behavior as
studied in animal models in mice we look
at Imola and we'll look at tuberculosis
so when we talk about tuberculosis we
really have a project a collection of a
lot of samples there have been recently
a number of studies on microbial
resistance to antibiotics and
tuberculosis is a good example it's a
micro bacterium and it is treated with
different types of treatments in
different locations geographically so we
can collect the type of treatments and
the response to treatment how effective
it was and really study the genomic
compositions of tuberculosis to
understand the relationship between
specific mutation
in the genome and the effect on the
treatment we will also look at Ebola
where we will study a collection of all
the Ebola samples from the 2014 2016
Ebola outbreak in Africa and we will
talk about how the different positions
on the genome once they mutate as a
response to this evolution of viral
adaptation to new populations right if
you think about viruses viruses what is
unique about them is that they have a
short genome and to overcome any kind of
hosts response if we talk about the
immune response if we talk about the
challenges of barriers between different
organs then to adapt to the responses
and to the defense systems that organism
the host organism has the virus has to
mutate different regions of its genome
and as I mentioned the viruses these
types of viruses really evolved as
communities and so we can look at the
community evolution and understand
fitness of different mutations to study
how viral adaptation can be correlated
with for example geographic distribution
or with outcomes how lethal it is
another aspect of these types of studies
a translational value of these studies
beyond mechanistic understanding of how
these viruses adapt and overcome these
different defense mechanisms is the
ability to design vaccines and so we
know that this outbreak the 2014-2016
outbreak which was one of the deadliest
outbreaks of Ebola but today we know
there's another outbreak of Ebola it did
lead to development of new vaccines and
the development of new vaccines is
actually very critical for prevention of
further outbreaks and one of the
limitations of the Matan vaccines is
this process of mutation so if we train
the organ of iris mutates and then the
caps
doesn't look like that anymore how do we
actually address that problem right and
the problem could be addressed addressed
by finding the most conserved regions
and the ones that are critical for the
viral replication cycle so we'll talk a
little bit about some of these concepts
in the context of this ebola project
another study is an example of how we
can use genome-wide Association studies
typically studies that are performed on
larger species but in the context of
bacterial genomes and a good example is
rise of bacteria bacteria that forms on
the roots of specific plants and can
have an impact on how these plants can
utilize the resources in the soil around
them transforming them to functional
material for its growth and fruit
production and others so really a
variety of projects ranging from
biomedical to you can say behavioral
right like the gut brain access project
and to agriculture so really we can see
the impact of the study of microbiology
and the study of metagenomics is is very
vast now we'll also talk about how to
take data from the public domain
how can one that you know all of you
joining the program how can you find
interesting datasets and understand one
type of sequencing how the data was
generated what is the context of the
phenotypes that we are studying in the
data how do we translate that into a
logical scheme of steps just like we saw
in this pipeline right here right all of
these sections are represented by very
logical step-by-step sections that you
can utilize to address a very specific
problem so problems of really
understanding the processing of data how
do we prepare data for analysis and to
prepare data for analysis
as we saw in this example we have to
understand what the challenges aren't
right so by going through some of these
examples we'll see what the challenges
are we will also then try to understand
the analysis part this analysis part
with final seek really allows us to
study composition and compare
composition between samples to then
interpret how that might affect for
example a certain condition and that's a
correlation that you need to identify as
well so we will learn about the data
inputs we will talk about the logic of
the analysis and we will talk about the
data sets how do we find those data sets
how do we go on repositories like the
NCBI and like some of these other
repositories which have quite a
collection of samples to study the whole
project so just a quick overview of some
of these materials a lot of the
materials that we will be going through
in these online sessions are going to be
focused on supplement information to the
online courses that you can find here
now the courses that we have here start
all the way from free courses that Union
for example this course is focused on
this American gut metagenomic sequencing
project but you also get a lot more
practice and a lot more guided program
by joining the program that we have
online such as this program so it's very
important to understand the relationship
between some of these different elements
that I'm showing and the relationship is
that really if you think of a program
that you have access to somebody to talk
to ask questions get feedback on your
project idea really understand what is
it that you want to do and help you get
there that is the program if you already
know what you're doing and you would
like to just understand how to apply a
specific analysis method to a data set
that you have have
me what you can get is a research access
to this platform where you can upload
your own data run some of these analyses
get the output and you will still get
feedback from our team on how to do it
better and how to leverage some of the
other resources that might take a while
to learn about on this whole platform
and the other one is really if you don't
feel like you're ready for a program
like this you don't think that you will
be working on your own project you don't
think that you need to understand the
depths of the metagenomic sequencing and
project examples you would just like to
explore what is metagenomics and how can
it be relevant you can start with a free
course for example one of the courses
that you can start with for free there
of course called introduction to
metagenomics introduction to manage
genomics right here and in this course
we actually cover a lot of the base
areas that you can benefit from now in a
second I'll be wrapping up and I would
be happy to address any questions that
you might have about the program itself
or talk about how some of the previous
programs have helped some of the
participants that we've worked with to
achieve their goals so you can learn a
little bit about that we've recently
published a couple of blogs or team put
out on how other participants for
example you can see here dr. Melissa
Bratton from Xavier University in New
Orleans dr. Zeko from Florida
International University you have some
other people that have joined some of
our previous programs and have really
benefited from the research aspects from
the educational aspects and really from
understanding the logic of the analysis
so with that I am going to wrap up the
presentation part of the story and open
up the platform for anyone first of all
from our team that would like to add to
what I've
in this discussion and feel free to talk
about some of the more technical aspects
of the program including any scheduling
questions about timing for international
students or us-based students as well as
some of the aspects of how the program
certificates work you will get a
certificate of participation based on
your activity based on what you do
throughout the program and how many
sessions you join if you have any
questions about the research platform
and how that works we can also talk
about that but also of course all of you
are welcome to continue and stay in
touch with us by email or there is a
chat box on the website itself where you
can just type in your messages so it
will be happy to answer any of those
questions so I'll pause now and let
anybody else add to what I've said or if
you have any questions please feel free
to type in your question in the chat box
you
mohit would you like to add anything
about the scheduling of the program
you
yeah thank you yeah you know first of
all I would like to thank everyone for
joining this meeting and as Elia
mentioned that we'll be starting with
started this program today and there
will be another webinar through the
process
we have organization page
reprogrammed so it's like a classroom
where all the participants can see their
progress we will be describing those in
the next session of as well so I will
just take you to the organization page
and show you the schedule of the program
you
you
so here is the chat box that Elia was
talking about where you can type in your
questions regarding any queries that you
have so you can just click here and
write about the question
and asked us
so so as for the next session we will be
starting on we will be talking on 16s
metagenomic sequencing on 1st of
November
on 5th of November we will be talking
about microbiome and hence again on 8th
of November which is a Tuesday will be
again talking about the analysis
challenges we will be talking about
short reads as we are or to use and will
be discussing in depth the pipelines
used for the analysis of 16s metagenomic
data and then on Friday will be
discussing mapping on databases and on
15 will be doing the data to pipeline
that Elia just showed you so on 15 we
will be taking a break where we will be
letting you do a project so those
projects as mentioned there are multiple
projects in our platform which which is
if we if you can see here you can go
into this and see the projects so you'll
be doing metagenomic projects project
for a month so we will be resuming on
10th of December again so that the
second phase will be more on the
research topics so we will be covering
bacterial population jiva's analysis of
genome-wide Association studies and then
again on 13th we'll be talking about
viral genome detection in standard RNA
sequence so after that we will have few
more sessions on phylogenetic analysis
and drug resistance on 20th and we'll be
concluding on on 23rd with a program
with one-on-one discussion so that would
be all for this overview so I'll give
the stage back to the Ilia or the if
anyone has any question please feel free
to ask us so
just stop the [ __ ] yep Thank You Mohit
and yes anyone that would like to
benefit from all of the aspects of the
program again you're welcome to still
register we have several sessions
planned and all of these sessions are
going to be recorded and shared with all
of the participants that have registered
all of you will get access to the free
courses the paid projects and also a
educational license to the server
platform that I just demonstrated and a
lot of guidance and one-on-one
interaction with each one of our team we
have an experienced team that has been
working in metagenomic data analysis for
a while and has participated in a number
of publications as well as these courses
are being taught in a number of
different organizations around the world
where we have college level and high
school level programs that are also
designed for faculty and to learn about
some of these topics and develop
projects with students together with
them so again feel free to ask any
questions if we don't have any questions
we will be wrapping up this session here
in a few minutes in about five minutes
and then after the session we'll be
happy to share with you some of the
recordings that we have for this session
yes hello I just wanted to know if I
have registered for another program it's
the data analysis and the biomedical
sciences is till I have to register
again for this post yeah you since
you're already registered and another
program you can ask for a discount would
be happy to provide that for you but
this is a separate program that will
cover completely different topics and
well
spend two months so just in general to
everyone how these programs work we have
six to eight programs per year focused
on different aspects of violin from
Attucks starting from genomics
transcriptomics metagenomics epigenomics
machine learning for biomedical data and
an introductory program so we can hold
these programs throughout the year
they're all several months long from one
month to three months and so the payment
that we are requiring or the program is
actually based on one month access to
all these resources and the program
there is however a an unlimited
subscription that gives you access to
all of the programs and the server
platform to analyze your own data so you
can also inquire about that if you're
interested in kind of pursuing multiple
programs at the same time okay thank you
okay well thank you everyone for joining
again if you have any questions feel
free to reach out to us I believe that
she also posted a link to join the
whatsapp group if you're comfortable
using that for communication we'd be
happy to see you there
I am very excited about this program to
start we'll be meeting again soon and we
are all excited to see you there so
hopefully you can email us or continue
communicating with us in any way that's
best for you and we'll see you soon and
with that I will end this presentation
and like we mentioned we will send out
the recording of this session and any
other information that we mentioned
during the session by email and looking
forward to seeing you again soon
you
you
you